[Applaudissements]
vous
sur tout
oui mais la bonne entame et super fun
c'est aussi à ça fait ça
[Applaudissements]
ça va
bourdon
[Applaudissements]
on
il tente en plus si vous avez bien
ce qu'on peut rentrer c'est la vérité
[Applaudissements]
com
deloitte
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce
la thérapie
on s'arrête 2000
[Musique]
excuse moi non à la tire à la petite
amie emma
[Musique]
quand il
dans ce concours
[Musique]
une autre
car si tous deux leur emploi
c'est un don
oui
je pense
à quel âge vous
il faut parler
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui matin
des coûts
ce que
c'est
je
de perturber
ces cafés
je crois pas
il averti
les mêmes mecs là
p
à
je
aurea papier
j'aimais
je
[Musique]
votons pas fait
les retirer
pour
m
c
notamment
[Musique]
qui veut pas
la plastique
m
c
[Applaudissements]
encore
oui
l'a fait roi
pas nous
m
alors qu'hier
les baisses
on va papa
parti
bon
[Musique]
de l'amour
alors
[Musique]
beaucoup
oui
et
bon
ou pas
c'est
le
en mai
[Musique]
vous
dabi
voilà
il
non
oui c'est un tabou
paris katherine
voilà
on s'est repris
[Musique]
il faut
les enfants
hors jeu
je reconnais tout
non
c'est le schéma
donc
non
[Applaudissements]
m
on
mère divorcée meny mazouz accords
c'est déjà sur la mauvaise pratique
c
m
quand même
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
bon
un coup de coeur
oui
et
ne pas réaliser maintenant je réalise
pas vous n'êtes pas les droits
les jeux c'est fini je sais
dans un resto voilà d'ailleurs la vie
notre vie
plein de choses
c'est maintenant au milieu qui a pris la
photo nous voilà les yeux parlent pas
besoin de se parler avec le regard sacré
mec et l'allemagne arrivé là il veut
l'avouer au gaz dire qu'il est là 28 ans
sais tu que tu t'en tous les deux aux
filles trois bottés trois caractères
différents
il m'a comblé en fait complètement
tellement de niveaux
c'est aujourd'hui il ya pas beaucoup de
couples qui tiennent autant d'années
vraiment il y en a très peu
on a dérapé comme j'ai pu le dire on a
fait du grand n'importe quoi mais on a
été solides rappelle le conseiller au
bout jusqu'au bout
il faut tenir moi je suis prête je tiens
mon mari mon mec on le touche pas
[Applaudissements]
il
une idée
[Applaudissements]
mais oui
bon
ça fait mal
non
c
ça
le coup
bon
le
[Musique]
j'ai tout court
oui
non
des libertés
wen
pour beaucoup
clé de la voix
avec moi je n'ai vraiment les réseaux et
aux couches de peinture voilà vous savez
s'il a vécu dans l'art et 4 je pense que
c'est ça
la voilà les mêmes même si elle est plus
de symptômes
on
j'appelle
oui
m
on
je me rends compte que vous êtes
nombreux
je le savais déjà la base mais je marque
encore vous êtes donc elle aimait à
l'apprécier je parle de chronos plus
qu'aux particuliers
et voyez moi je vous apprécie aussi pas
tous mais et je vais vous dire un truc
je vais me battre pour lui vous savez
certains le savent
avec des filles on va se battre pour lui
d'aller jusqu'au bout on prendra du
temps de la force l'énergie mais on on
en trouve on a un peu moins envie de
pleurer aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
beaucoup pleuré la tristesse est
toujours là elle est présente mais on a
un nous les quatre une force qui est en
train de se développer qui est assez
importante et on est hyper motivé les
quatre nanas sont hyper motivés et donc
on va se battre pour nous en priorité
bien évidemment mais pour les gars de
crohn ou plus dont philippe adore et qui
connaît depuis longtemps et pour vous
les gars b je vais vraiment me battre je
vous donne ma parole
la même parole que j'ai donnée à
philippe car je lui ai dit c'est la même
chose à l'oreille
sachez le
[Applaudissements]
à
donc
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
on
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
il
ouais voilà
rabat on va beaucoup
la famille
l'exemple et lisa
allemagne et leurs biens
bon
d'accord
[Musique]
merci
j'en achetais on sera encore voyait déjà
belge vous remercier parce qu'il connaît
même si c'est il est donc grande douleur
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais juste vous demander quelque
chose parce qu'en fait je vois ça arrive
ça arrive ça arrive savoir si vraiment
de tout rompre
il est fini parce que oui parce que s'il
ya des anonymes et mes cd million de
mercis aussi comme je veux dire c'est
incroyable ce qu'on est en train d'y et
j'ai l'impression de vivre un rêve dans
un cauchemar
de toute manière et cette fabuleuse
j'ai pas c'est pas bien aussi
[Applaudissements]
on discute parce que j'en ai fait
beaucoup 40 10 heures donc je m'en fous
je pense vous des moments
donc voilà je voulais vous dire à tous
on voulait me méfie de moi ma famille
bien évidemment de mon papa de me rendre
mon frère de tout ce client philippe
prix infini qui a dominé en fait vu ces
phénomènes voilà je voulais remercier du
plus profond de mon coeur de nos tripes
parce que ça va loin et puis vous dire à
quel point vous êtes important parce que
là je me rends compte j'ai un soutien
qui ne m'a pas fait beaucoup pleuré ce
soir et ouais bizot qui m'a pas fait
beaucoup pleuré et je la vends je crois
que j'ai pu j'ai assez pleuré je pense
que là maintenant la force elle en train
de me le prendre le dessus et c'est bien
parce que je veux bien me battre comme
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
donc voilà je vais pas si c'est trop
longtemps si vous voulez boire après y'a
pas de soucis je les aime en particulier
par contre c'est pas cette personne et
là je veux juste qu'on sache une chose
je veux que cette personne ne sache
aussi philippe ne devait pas travailler
dimanche il a remplacé une collègue de
travail qui culpabilise amour il est
hors de question qu elle culpabilise
je sais qui c'est à peu près sept
personnes pleurent parce qu'elle a peur
de me rencontrer ce que je trouve tout à
fait normal mais si elle est dans l
celle-là je veux qu'elles entendent ou
sinon vous vous direz
quelle peut venir me voir mais sans
problème elle est responsable de rien
dans ce qui s'est passé et pour bien
qu'à son instinct dans la tête mais moi
je lui confirme donc encore voilà un
commercial
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
des centaines
bonjour
oui
alors ce soir devant jouer la victoire
il a vu nous
attention vous avez une sonde
donc on a dû changer pour l'ouverture de
la et changer la trajectoire est passée
comme la série on a dit la navigation
des neuf et 48 heures ouais voilà faut
attendre
je ne peux pas vous dire qu'il va mieux
tu peux juste vous dire qu'il ya un
point positif dans sur lequel on peut se
raccrocher quand même parce que moi je
cherche toujours le moindre espoir donc
là j'ai un petit espoir qui est très
minime et mais il est quand même présent
c'est que grâce à cette somme il ya fait
bon et c'est là la tension artérielle
qui est dans une stabilité organique et
avec ça on peut me permettre de diminuer
le titre e
les doses de voir comment ça se passe
c'est pour ça qu'on peut attendre c'est
beaucoup
derrière je suis merci
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
on va tout
[Applaudissements]
voilà
des mots latins passé beaucoup plus
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas qui je suis une battante
philippe et en partant je suis une
battante pas m'emmerder en fait
je vais aller jusqu'au bout je me
donnerai la promesse j'ai donné ma
promesse au chauffeur parce que aussi
faut pas les oublier je crois hyper
important bonjour
[Applaudissements]
fils jett the six équipements de crier
que j'ai beaucoup de chemin encore ça va
être compliqué ça veut dire je suis une
battante et en principe j'arrive à me
faire en principe mais j'ai confiance
mais qui sont là j'ai confiance mais
j'insiste sur quelque chose
les chauffeurs de bus faut pas les
oublier
qui tient vraiment ça l'est vraiment
parce que même ça en l'honneur du
philips nous fasse oublier parce que je
suis en train de vivre il est hors de
question qu'un chauffeur ou une femme
chauffeur vivent la même chose ça peut
pas exister cc c'est notre planète le
matériau mondiale éclate et rire se
rendre compte ce qui se passe quand je
prends pas le bij parce que j'ai pas
envie et j'appelle bus et puis on sait
jamais sur qui on tombe donc céder quoi
je parle donc je prends pas lui et je
veux dire quelque chose des gars qui
sont dans le muscle est mon peu de son
nouveau - nouveau sens y un ancien
je suis sûr que des moments où il se
lève et jean mallot enfin je pense
vraiment voilà il se met à busan ballon
rentre donc on peut pas oublier
on ne peut pas occulter ça et puis faire
un discours
bla bla moi non c'est pas ça ce sont des
actes qu'il faut et des choses qu'il
faut la concrète la très vite fait très
vite la sécurité
[Applaudissements]
ça va être ce mettre les derniers n'ont
tué j'oublie voilà encore une fois je
vous remercie vraiment vraiment nous
pendant mon nom mais je dit tellement de
choses je parle tellement aux
journalistes on mâche un bandana que je
sais puisque le client j'ai des moments
d'absence
mais voilà nous vous remercions de votre
présence de votre soutien des messages
sur les réseaux sociaux des choses
changent pour des pâquis me retrouver
des photos ou des montages photo d c'est
beau c'est magnifique c'est voilà tout
et vous vous êtes la vie en fait et ça
c'est une preuve
et merci d'aider des millions froid oui
comment à quand la justice et
malheureusement je n'ai pas été encore
reçu par la police donc laissant faire
les choses ma priorité aujourd'hui c'est
philippe voilà donc le seul chose en son
temps
ma priorité c'est philippe chaque fois
la jeunesse avait dix ans de procédure
pour une maison à bayonne je peux quoi
je peux continuer quand les cheveux en
acheter s'oriente donc je m'en fiche ma
priorité c'est terrible la justice m'a
entendu j'espère il ya tellement de
reportages que je pense qu'elle va
m'entendre
elle va m'aider à me venger parce que
c'est avec la justice peut jouer
mais manger et donc on va laisser faire
les choses
y aurait t c'est mon petit diamant qui
enroule un diamant donc ça il est
gallois
on va se battre on va voir la dernière
chose je voudrais fêter parce qu'un
certain je commence à faire douter
georgette de sourire de temps en temps
parce que vous savez j'ai tellement peur
on a tellement pleuré que des fois on
dit des bêtises et puis un petit sourire
donc je vous permets de dire des pas du
tout c'est la vie aussi il était vrai
c'est vrai donc je voudrais insister là
dessus on sait aujourd'hui où on en est
on sait ce que filippi là on se donne
encore quelques deux jours on va dire l
48 heures manière je tiendrai informé
les proches de trop non plus et voilà je
refuse je demande à ce que je sais pas
combien vous êtes chez qobuz que donne
aucune idée ça prend deux chauffeurs de
ces conneries 11 pas policiers qui sont
volant voilà on va dire balle et blanc
ça ne peut pas faire de bêtises on va
dire l'ensemble du corpus voilà je
voudrais surtout demandé qu'il ne soit
vraiment pas oubliée voilà il ya eu il
ya une catastrophe qui est là il ya une
destruction de vies qui est là il ya
destruction de vies de fabriquer la noce
et une destruction de de deux coups on
est forts vont y arriver mais il ne faut
pas les oublier
je demande vraiment quand qu'on soit
avec eux les choses soient faites pour
eux qui se lèvent le matin en se disant
qu'on joue grand
chez moi parce que je sais comment
protéger voilà surtout ça c'est ce que
je voulais insister là dessus
[Applaudissements]
le
elle pas du tout
[Musique]
par conte embrasser philippe de la part
de tout le monde voit et on est tous
allés lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est normal c'est normal et si vous
avez besoin à la communauté des
chauffeurs et la la
ça brasse le d'autres pas à pas sans
l'autre
les visites sont pas fondées
là
la ville
quoi
[Applaudissements]
la plage
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'accusatrice
paris perd même
je
mais
le temps
voilà
m
devez-vous
[Musique]
ouais
est monté
qui
il est
à laisser leurs amis
faire